موعد الاحتجاجات هذه ليست صدفه 400 الف
عامل من موظفي القطاع العام من بينهم عمال
مترو الانفاقنا في لندن يضربون عن العمل
تزامنا مع اعلان الميزانيه العامه في مجلس
العموم تحاول النقابات من خلال هذه
الاحتجاجات والاضات الضغط على الحكومه من
اجل رفع اجورهم وتخليصهم من اعباء البلاد
الاقتصاديه التي يقولون انها اصبحت سيئه
للغايه
[تصفيق]
انا اشارك في الاضراب حقيقه لكل ما يحدث
في هذا البلد ليس فقط من اجل المعلمين
ولكن لكافه العاملين في البلاد
انا هنا اليوم لادعم والدتي لانها مدرسه
دائما ما تتاخر ولا تصل المنزل الا بعد
حلول الليل
وزير الماليه في مجلس العموم اليوم رد على
الغاضبين من الميزانيه العامه بضريبه على
ارباح الشركات وباجراءات اجتماعيه قلم
تتخذها حكومه يمنيه محافظه
[تصفيق]
بسبب العوامل الدوليه المتغيره وتدابير
التي اتخذتها لن تدخل بريطانيا في ركود
هذا العام
لكن لا يبدو ان المحتاجين هنا مقتنعون
بالموازنه الجديده حيث يصلون على ان موظفي
القطاع العام هم جديرون برفع اجورهم
اضرابات واحتجاجات اعطت فرصه للاحزاب
السياسيه المعارضه وعلى راسها حزب العمال
لنسم الوضع الاقتصادي المتردي لسياسات
تقول انها فاشله من قبل حزب المحافظين
الحاكم منذ اكثر ما يزيد على عقد من الزمن
من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه